the following is a conversation with
giannis pappas a comedian who co-hosted
the podcast
history hyenas that i came across when i
was researching the battle of crete from
world war
ii he and his co-host were hilarious
in their rants about history and about
life
the chemistry they have is probably the
best of any co-hosted comedy podcast
or even podcasts in general that i've
ever heard
as of a few weeks ago unfortunately
history hyenas is no more at least for
now
because all good things must come to an
end but giannis
hosts a new podcast called long days
with giannis papas
plus he has a comedy special on youtube
for free quick mention of our sponsors
wine access blinkist magic spoon
and indeed check them out in the
description to support this podcast
as a side note let me say that some of
you have noticed
that i have not spoken with too many
computer scientists physicists
biologists or engineers recently
the reason has to do mostly with the
risk aversion of many of these folks
in the time of covid especially as they
get closer to taking the vaccine
i'm tested several times a week and
still some people are just more willing
than others to have
an in-person conversation in these times
i only do these podcasts in person
because i look for the possibility of a
genuine human connection
i'm willing to sacrifice a lot for that
maybe it's silly but i look for the
magic that
charles bukowski writes about in his
poem nirvana
the magic that is somehow in the air on
those rare occasions
when two people meet talk and you notice
that while on the surface you may be
worlds apart
you're still somehow woven from the same
fabric
i've had that with many guests jim
keller comes to mind but
many others as well i'm an ai person
machine learning robotics computer
science is my passion
trust me i can't wait to be having more
technical conversations again
but i will also continue to mix in
comedians musicians historians
and of course wise all-seeing sages like
giannis pappas and tim dillon just to
keep it
as tim likes to say fun
this is the lex friedman podcast and
here
is my conversation with giannis pappas
you've co-hosted until recently an
amazing
history comedy podcast called the
history hyenas
so you're a bit of a student of history
yeah uh
an f student of history f student yeah
okay i thought it was more like a d
minus
d minus yeah okay still got to repeat
the grade if you get all d minuses i
actually had a point 67 gpa
average my freshman year and i had to do
it again this is this podcast is going
to be the spectrum of human intelligence
this
it runs from there to here so this is
going to set the low
bar i'm barely sliding into human i'm
closer to chimp
and i uh bring that up that you're also
friends with uh
the great the powerful tim dillon
so let's talk about power and the
corrupting effects of power
sometimes i look at tim dillon as he
grows in power i thought you meant it
in size well size i think they're
correlated yeah
i saw him i've been in austin a couple
days i saw him once we had eight meals
in one day
eight meals yeah so i feel like i've
been here longer than i have just
because of the meals with dylan
kid likes biscuits and barbecue okay so
he's more like see i was i was imagining
putin or something like that he's more
like the north korean
dictator they'd get along great those
two
yeah they would get i mean tim dillon
and king john um would be like they
could make like a buddy cop movie they
would get along like lethal weapon
that would be a good pitch movie great
podcast yeah that would be a great
podcast
yeah so much to talk about so many
similar ideas about the world
so what do you think the world would
look like
if tim dillon was given absolute power
he seems like a person
that's an interesting study of the
corrupting effects of power
yeah you don't want to give him power
you don't want i don't even want him
wearing a suit
like i want a guy who's as thoughtful
and educated as you wearing a suit
like because you know suits corrupt you
you put that suit on you start feeling
that power you see definitely
it's like you know yeah i don't even
want tim dylan to suit power would
he would kill people he'd get rid of
anything that he deemed
i mean if you made a lobster roll and it
wasn't up to tim dillon's standard he
would have you executed
the restaurant staff is just gone
he would have people below his food
standard execute there'd be programs
not of people who are political
dissidents but of people who don't meet
his food standard his cuisine standard
is high
and he's usually right do you think
power does corrupt people
yes like one of the reasons we mentioned
offline joe rogan
he's been an inspiration to me because
he gets he gets
forget power just more famous and famous
and yes probably a bit of power in terms
of influence
and he's still pretty much the same guy
i'm not sure that's going to be true for
everybody
do you ever think ask yourself with that
question yeah he's a rare breed
he's like a benign king i've most people
i meet who are like really powerful are
like
douchebags and that's how they got there
i think that's psychopaths have the
advantage because they don't have
feelings
and joe's a rare example he's just a
powerhouse of will
and uh he uh i do think about that yeah
i think i should be stopped right now
just stop me right now because yeah
power for me i would
when people get power they indulge i
don't think it changes anyone it just
reveals your darkest
yeah you know people aren't supposed to
have anything they want you got to be
able to struggle for everything so i
would have a harem
i'd be like a roman dictator yeah i'd be
like a roman emperor i mean people call
them emperors they were dictators the
most effective leaders are dictators
i hope we get back to that democracy
hasn't worked i'm ready for a secession
of caesar's
and i want to start with aoc
that's true dictators get the job done
they do they do at certain point you go
that's why social workers can only get
you so far you need
action i was a social worker for five
years and all you do is ask about
medications and
you don't solve anything i do ask myself
of that like
because i'm more in the tech space of
constructing
systems that prevent me from being
corrupt because
right now i'm all about love and all
about those kinds of things
but i wonder you said like it just
reveals the darkness
the the problem is we might not be aware
of our own darkness
i have the same feeling about money
actually i've been avoiding
thinking about money like basically
constructing my moral system my moral
compass around money
it's like the moment i feel a little too
happy
but about the idea of owning some cool
shiny thing
i started to think okay i'm not gonna
own that shiny thing
because i'm afraid of the slippery slope
of it yeah you ever think about that
kind of stuff
yeah the the funny thing about our the
capitalist system is it's uh
it's um it puts sort of uh profit motive
above
beauty and you notice when you see
certain cities
especially in the old days where like
buildings used to be beautiful
yeah and uh now they're just like boxes
they throw a kid up and it's just for
all profit margin
it's um it's the illusion of permanence
that uh
you know it's like oh let me get as much
money as i can you're like yeah you know
my dad used to say you know everyone
it's a cliche but you can't take it with
you so it's kind of it's it's comical to
me
that we're here trying to get this
infinite amount like that we're climbing
it's like
sisyphus we're all trying to climb this
hill but i mean the rock's gonna fall on
us so i think that's a healthy outlook
yeah
my dad always used to say before he
passed you know he would say you can't
you have to survive not only
physically but you have to survive
emotionally i think a lot of people
forget about the emotional part
of uh survival you have to survive
emotionally and humor
and and and understanding reality in its
objective context helps with that
accepting reality as this
ephemeral uh thing that
you're in really just a part of but not
as significant as your ego wants you to
believe
is a start that's a good foundation for
surviving emotionally
what what's that mean surviving
emotionally like what what's an ideal
life look like for you yeah you can't
driving you can't take things too
seriously you can't um because
they're ephemeral they're they're not
permanent nothing's permanent your bank
account's not permanent your problems
aren't permanent
uh nothing's permanent your abilities
aren't permanent um your memory is not
permanent your
your dick getting hard it's not
permanent can i curse on this or is this
go out
yeah you can curse to your heart's
content okay yeah i mean gender is not
even permanent anymore i think i'm gonna
i'm gonna change maybe and live my
second half as another gender just to
have
i'm bored with this gender so it's like
nothing is permanent
and so accepting that emotionally
uh is a good start to being more
flexible you got to be flexible
like my dad used to say anything too
stiff snaps you gotta
you know it's a cliche and people have
said it a bunch of different ways but
bruce lee's right man be
water be water
yeah bukowski has this quote about
love that love is a fog that phase with
the first light of reality
so he's a romantic that guy yeah but
that even love is a thing that just
doesn't last very long
no um you know some people disagree with
that maybe it morphs it
like like like water it changes right it
might not be
it might not be this because he's mostly
just uh loved like prostitutes i think
so that's kind of love yeah no demand no
uh responsibilities yeah it's a
financial transaction
yeah uh ephemeral as ever
you mentioned your dad he passed away
uh two a year and a half ago yeah
what did you learn from him i love my
dad
my dad i would say my dad was my my hero
he was just uh
my dad really embodied those values and
i think um
for better or worse it's made me who i
am he's he uh
my dad was was a painter he was a lawyer
he was uh
he was a you know a lieutenant in the
military new yorker
new yorker born and bred brooklyn his
doubt his dad you know uh surprise owned
a diner so that's
that's sort of the greek passport that's
the immigration passport for greeks in
new america
and um yeah my dad played football he
just my dad did what he wanted he lived
as he wanted at all costs and i think i
got that from him
for better or worse i think it's hurt me
in my pursuits
uh if if you consider money and fame
uh to be paramount you know i've always
done what i wanted if i stopped wanting
to do it i just stopped doing it i think
i got that for my dad so maybe
for better or worse that's what i
learned from them but that's a real
currency you know
feeling like you're in love with what
you're doing when you're doing it
maybe perhaps that's worth more than
money i don't know
you miss him yeah every day every day
but i'm happy that
uh he he got 91 years
it's very rare i mean he smoked for 60
years
talk about like a guy who was an outlier
and he smoked like six years like
packs i mean yeah and he didn't die from
that he died he had a
prostate cancer which is the way men
should go your dick should give out it
should start from the dick
i mean we focus so much of our life on
the dick that
that's the way that's a successful life
and that's why every man eventually gets
prostate cancer because that is the
universe's way of saying like
the thing you focused on the most is you
put the most energy into is the thing
that's spent
and it's gonna your your rotting is
gonna start there so that's a successful
life
and it just spread all over his body and
he slowly died i was with him when he
died and that meant a lot to me
because me and my brother weren't
talking at the time because we're greeks
uh
we're we're talking again but that's how
it is you got a few brothers right i got
two brothers
but i wanted to make sure i was with him
uh when he died and i got lucky and i
was in the room with him when he died
you were in the room with your brother
and you weren't no my brother wasn't
there we were kind of doing shifts i was
i was there i spent
the night the dad my the night my dad
died he died in the early in the morning
and i heard
the death rattle last breath and it was
just i think it was
uh i he knew i was there and i think
that just probably
meant something to him and i'm just glad
i was there does that make you sad
that uh life is ephemeral like you said
yeah that
you die yeah what do you think about
your own death you meditate on that
i think it i think the actual if there
is a point to life it's to
hopefully not fear death to accept
reality
i think that's important i think so much
goes awry in the human condition when we
lose touch with reality every political
system that's led to mass murder and
everything i think
because it's because the the tenets
of those political philosophies ended up
being utopian they were detached from
reality
detached from nature and so i think it's
it's very important to accept and
acknowledge your own mortality i think
it's the foundation for what makes a
good person a moral person
um a contributing member of society
because it's true
true things should be the foundation of
all things
if if if what you believe is based on
illusion you're gonna end up doing
destruction
whether that destruction is on a scale
of one to ten you are going to be
destructive because it's not real
it's a fantasy it doesn't exist see the
thing is the truth is about
i don't think you can ever reach truth
truth is about like constantly digging
and to push back in your idea that you
should accept death i think the more
honest response to death
so the least honest is to run away from
it create illusions
that help you imagine that there's not a
death
the next is to accept it but the real
honest one is to fear it
because i i i mean i'm with
ernest becker as a philosopher uh he
wrote a book called denial of death
he says that the like much of the human
condition is based in the fear of
mortality
that we like that's that's the creative
force of the human energy like freud
said you want to sleep with your mother
he said no that's not what motivates you
maybe his mom wasn't hot though
i mean or he wasn't greek because
apparently edible we we found
we found that all things good and bad
yeah thanks thanks for that thanks
i just don't know if his mom was look or
not i mean i have to google it all right
yeah i'll look up on google images
yeah no but i think that honest as he
says
the thing that we run away from is that
there's a terror he calls it like
terror there's something called terror
management theory that's
some philosophers after him followed on
that were basically trying to run away
from this fear
and acceptance is actually creating an
illusion for yourself
like you can actually accept something
as terrifying as this
so he's more with the stoics the stoic
constantly meditate on their death i
mean they
what does that mean that means kind of
you know acceptance of death isn't a
thing you do like
on a monday and then you're done it's a
thing you constantly have to meditate on
like reminding yourself like this ride
is over
it could be over today and that's
something you're if you think about
every single day
it gives you an appreciation of woody
allen movies at least
it gives you appreciation for basically
everything including woody allen movies
which shows you
how deep your appreciation for life
could be
i've actually haven't been following
much about what woody allen's
but apparently he's been a troublemaker
throughout most of his life
he's yeah i mean you know he's caused a
little bit of strife he's left a little
uh
yeah he's left a little confusion in his
wake for sure
but i mean you know that's another one
separate the art from the artist
he's got i mean the guys will go down in
history as the greatest
he's i mean a movie a year and they're
all you can always find something good
about each movie like the dialogue or
whatever
um i love what you're saying it's
interesting but the only thing i would
say to push back a little bit since
we're playing a little table tennis here
yeah
is um i don't know if it's a choice to
fear death that's more of an
it seems more instinctual it seems like
something that
nature wants you to do because i've been
in positions where i thought i was gonna
die like i've been shot and
i had those moments and then nature also
uh you know kicks in an instinct which
is acceptance
where you kind of i don't know it's a
chemical release or whatever i don't
know you know
we're all we're robots basically so some
sort of chemical is released that
protects you but
there is an acceptance i don't know how
much uh
of it was a conscious choice probably
very little um
and that's the point i'm making is it's
instinctual we don't really have a
choice
in fearing death otherwise there would
be no progression we wouldn't
all life seems to want to survive
uh not by choice but by instinct
so he he argues that the fear is not the
instinctual of it's not the animalistic
stuff that's the thing that makes us
special
is the what humans are able to do is
they have a knowledge that we're going
to die one day animals don't have that
animals fear is instinctual it's like
holy [ __ ] what's that sound over there
he says we're actually able to
contemplate the fact that this ride ends
and that that kind of cognitive
construct
is difficult for us to deal with like
what the hell does that mean
like just just to think about
it's going to be over at a certain point
like it's just over lights out like
it's very difficult to kind of load that
into
whatever this like little brain we got
like what does that actually mean
maybe that's what gives everything
meaning yeah
because if everything lasted forever if
uh if this went on an
infinite there would be no meaning to it
i'd be like hey if i don't see you
tomorrow i'll see in a million years
there would be no meaning there'll be no
urgency there would be no feelings
there'd be no uh nothing of magnitude or
superficiality it would all just be this
kind of
it would be torture it would actually
that would actually be torture
to be here forever i mean i'm already
sick of this place and i'm
just in my 40s like i'm done i'm sick of
me i'm sick of everything
you know a lot of people when they talk
about immortality they consider
they consider mortality appealing
because you get a chance to do
basically all these things
you might not get a chance to do
otherwise like all the kinds of travel
broadly explore read every book explore
every idea
do every hobby all those kinds of things
somebody else i was talking to mentioned
the reality of being immortal would be
more likely i like this idea more likely
would be
you just sitting there doing nothing
because and putting off all that
travel and exploration till later
because you'll always have time
and so what you're going to have what
actual immortality would look like
for a bunch of humans is people sitting
there doing nothing it'll be like a
greek cafe just sitting around drinking
coffee watching it i love it
yeah it's a lazy man's paradise yeah
but it's so interesting because that
that's that rings true to me for
what humans are like is we'll basically
just put off
all those exciting adventures and just
be lazy become lazier and lazier and
lazier
because you'll always have a chance to
do all the exciting things and we'll
just get
we'll basically become tim dill just sit
there and have a podcast
and that's it he works hard um yeah i
mean that sounds actually like heaven
dude that's speaking of my heart really
i mean
i'm at heart i'm a very lazy person i
always
try to find ways to lie down like if i'm
sitting i'll figure out a way to kind of
contort myself to later
that's an interesting thing to like in
yeah if you can
always push something off
yeah that i like that i i think that's
heaven
and um see we just changed your mind you
kind of like del mortality
yeah i kind of like it no so there'll be
no thirsts no
you can always put it off hey i wanna i
wanna i wanna have i wanna
bang this girl you're like i'll put it
off but now i'm thinking about muslim
heaven and they may be offering the best
deal i mean if it was an expo
and they had a booth i may go with them
because they offer
they offer 62 or 72 but then i'd get
sick of them i'd want to
i don't know i always wondered like are
you given the 62
virgins or do you choose can you create
them like an avatar
like a video game or are you just giving
i don't know what the num
why it's important to have that high
number first of all i think it's a
mistranslation about the virgins but
outside of that outside of that
i feel like the conversation is really
important i i don't think they ever
specify like what kind of books these
girls read
like what are they what are they into
like
the quality of the conversation i think
if you're talking about eternity the
quality of the intellect and the
conversation and the personalities is
way more important
and the greeks have an ancient ancient
expression pan metro narestone which my
mother always used to say which is
everything in moderation nothing in
excess so trying to always get the
status quo
and uh yeah that many women
eventually it's like the magic johnson
effect isaiah thomas effect
it's just too much and you're gonna end
up you're gonna end up banging a dude is
what i'm saying you're gonna get sick of
it because it's too much
and there's going to be a eunuch that
finds its way into your harem
that's been proven throughout history
every empire
when you have all that power and again
this goes back to power corrupting
if you have if there's no struggle
there's no meaning there's
the value is from the journey the the
working hard the struggle and if it's
just given to you because you're a
sultan
or you're alexander the great or
whatever you're going to get bored and
you're going to bang a dude
that's it's i think that's a scientific
axiom actually eventually you'll get
bored and banger dude
yeah but i think it won't stop there i
think you'll go to animals you'll go to
robot i mean
eventually it all ends up in robots and
then the robots rebel and then the
humans will be destroyed yeah
i'm sorry if if uh yeah we're speaking
truth you said
the value of life one of the
highest ideals is to seek truth i think
if we're gonna ask you a quick question
if
you uh if you live in a small i come
from small islands right and so there's
a stereotype that that's where they bang
animals but
if you come from a very small community
yes you know an island or something you
have the choice of banging a family
member or an animal which one is worse
on the moral scale
because you're technically not related
to the animal right
this is interesting i mean all of these
are human constructs these ideas but yet
for me personally taboo would be more
taboo to uh
to to have sex with a family member yeah
i mean animal i mean okay it's good to
know where you stand on that i think
your viewers you know that
if they didn't have they didn't know
they had that question i they just
learned a little bit about you and now i
know
i look forward to the internet clipping
that out
yeah i mean there there is listen uh in
some outside
outside of that i do think about that a
lot it sounds ridiculous
uh about morality connected to animals
in terms of all the the factory farming
and so on
it seems like that's one of the things
we'll look because i love me
but i kind of feel bad about it and and
bad in a way where i think if we look
like a hundred years from now
we'll look back at this time as like one
of the great
like tortures and injustices that we
humans have committed
and i mean all that has to do with the
sex with the animal has to do with
consent and about the experience of
suffering of animals
the reason i think about that personally
a lot because i think about
robotics i think about creating
artificial
consciousnesses uh artificial
like beings that have some elements of
the human nature and then
you start to think like well what does
it mean to suffer what does it mean
for entity to exist such that it
deserves rights
this is something that the founding
fathers were thinking about like
you know all men are created equal what
is it which
who's included in the men who who's not
in that in that sentence
and our animals included in that are
robots i honestly think that there will
be a civil rights movement for robots in
the future
i don't know is that the turing test the
way you try to is that they call it
where you're trying to
see if a ai can think like a human or
whatever or feel like a human
well it's uh the touring test closely
defined as more
about talk like a human so
you can you can imagine systems they're
able to you can have a conversation like
this and i would be a robot for example
but that doesn't mean i would in the
in society that doesn't mean i deserve
rights or
that doesn't mean i would be conscious
it doesn't mean that i would be able to
suffer
and to experience pleasure and dream and
all those kind of human things
the question isn't whether you're able
to talk which is passing the turing test
the question is whether you're able to
feel
to be uh i mean i go back to suffering
the thing that that our documents
protect us against
is uh suffering like we don't want
humans to suffer
and if a robot can suffer
that discussion starts being about like
well shouldn't we protect them currently
we don't protect animals
we protect dogs there's laws there's
actually legislation that protects dogs
for
certain places yeah and you know what
dogs is something i don't think people
really understand enough about
it's one of my obsessions so um they
they my dad always used to say though he
go those things those things are
basically human and i mean they dream
they have anxiety
uh and what people often overlook about
dogs is without dogs we wouldn't be here
we would not have ever evolved
from hunter-gatherer to agrarian to
you know civilization we wouldn't have
cities we wouldn't have anything i mean
they are our partner in
survival and they are a magical animal
there's no
there's no animal that was it was like
destiny almost i mean a malleable animal
there's no animal that's that malleable
that in a few generations you can tailor
to
a specific job that you need and without
that animal without dogs doing that
animal protecting our crops from
from uh you know uh scavengers and stuff
like that
you know the list goes on we wouldn't be
here
so we that's an often overlooked fact
that
human evolution was not uh done in a
vacuum just with humans i mean without
dogs we would have never evolved i mean
we weren't the apex predator for most of
our existence we weren't even the apex
predator
i mean we're getting eaten by hyenas
which is my favorite animal um and you
know it's kind of an injustice to
i mean i'm kind of mad at dogs die we
deserve to get eaten by hyenas but
without dogs we wouldn't be here and
dogs
dogs deserve the protection so do horses
they [ __ ] lugged us around
for thousands of years and now these
[ __ ] german psychopaths are eating
them or whatever
we should not eat horse meat just on
like be a good dude man these things
lugged us around for generations they're
beautiful
you know ride them or i don't know i
don't know but
it rubs me the wrong way that we eat
horses yeah the horse's one is
interesting
and one of my favorite books is animal
farm by orwell and the horses
don't get a good ending in that uh
i kind of uh my spirit animal i suppose
is the horse from animal farm
boxer where he says uh i will work
harder that's his motto
i i work really hard uh at stupid things
that's that's basically what i just hit
my head against the wall for no reason
whatsoever but that probably fulfills
you have a big brain you're probably
born with a big brain that kind of
fulfills
killing neurons it's exercise for you
yes yes
don't you think some animals deserve to
be eaten though kind of like
hyenas come on dude i mean they
gotta respect the hyena okay so let's
look first of all let me just comment on
the dog thing there is like conferences
on dog cognition
from a perspective of people that study
psychology cognitive science
neuroscience dogs are fascinating
the way they move their eyes they're
able to they're the only other animal
besides
humans they're able to communicate with
their eyes they can look at a thing
and look back at you and look back at
the thing to communicate that we're all
like
through our eyes communicate that we're
collaborating so
every other animal uses their eyes to
actually look at things
the dogs use it to like communicate with
you with us humans
it's fascinating there's a lot of other
elements of dogs that are amazing
yeah i mean if it wasn't for them
they're the ones they were our first
alarm system for predators they would
defend us
i mean the basenji is one of the most
ancient dogs i mean they're tiny but
they're fearless
yeah and they would chase off lions like
you know there'd be packs of them and
they'd chase off lions and
protect the tribes it's it's it's i even
get tingles like thinking about dogs
because i have a dog i love my dog it's
just
and there's something about when you're
walking with your dog off leash in the
woods it like
there's something about it that's like
that that
tugs at that uh millions of years of
evolution like
that gut you know it's like i had a
finished friend of mine he's a comic
tommy valamis once told me he was like
uh he was like the gut
he's like i believe in that like that
gut you know when you have that feeling
he's like always trust that because that
is million those are all your ancestors
that's
the survival instinct of all your
ancestors at the beginning of time
you know telling you like hey
something's off here something's you
know so don't get in the car with ted
bundy is what i'm saying ladies how
[ __ ] stupid
how can you fall for that you know he's
got a [ __ ] sling on don't get in
yeah follow the gut my question to you
are psychopaths
essentially robots so first of all let's
not you're using the word robot in a
derogatory way that i feel i'm
i'm triggered by okay
you should be because you know what
people are always scared of robots but i
i actually uh i have i've made the sort
of uh
i i've made it to say hey i've i thought
about it like robert robots have been
nothing but helpful
it's the people we should be scared of
right again we're kind of missing
the most destructive thing is us because
it's but robots
are helpful i mean this is a [ __ ]
robot you know i went on hotel tonight
i'm already booked up you know i got my
i can change my flight if if this
barbecue with rogan goes 16 hours which
whatever rogan wants to do i'll do if he
wants to kick me in the chest i'll let
him kick me in the chest whatever
um robots are helpful no
yeah tanks and autonomous weapon systems
don't kill people people kill people
yeah that's yeah yeah the nra's about to
collect that for you
a lot of love for dogs i appreciate it
very much and at the same time
you have the other thing that people
seem to have love for which is cats
and on the flip side of everything
you've said
i'm trying to understand what have cats
ever done for human civilization
they keep rodents away the domesticated
cat is very important
keeps rodents away yeah that's what they
were domesticated for i mean they're
psychopathic killers who end up
killing uh innocent um
neighborhood chipmunks and yeah and
birds
uh they really affect the uh the balance
of the local ecosystem but if you look
for cats too
not as much as dogs i mean dogs are like
you said they look at humans i actually
read an article there some people were
theorizing they're smarter than chimps
because
of the way they can work with humans and
there was one border collie that spoke
like
300 words like a quarter like a lang
almost
part of the language and their nose is
like a ma i mean that's like magic dude
if you can smell in my ass to what i had
for breakfast from
miles away that's intelligent that's
intelligence i mean in some ways that
their nose if you were to put it on a
scale maybe their nose is more
intelligent than our brain
for what it does you know it's like i
mean dude they can smell you from miles
away you ever see a dog just like
sniffing catching
i mean it's smelling like i don't
remember the the date on it but it's
like they have like millions of
receptors or something where we only
you know thank god we don't have their
nose that would be
that would make sex weird
be a little too intense i think you
mentioned when you were talking about
woody allen separating the
the art from the artist so that brings
to mind vladimir putin
[Laughter]
how about that transition i don't know
i'm so sorry
but if you look at just powerful leaders
throughout history stalin hitler
but yeah even moderate ones like putin
and we were talking about power
how do you explain them you said uh that
power
reveals not corrupts
but do you think there's some element
to which power corrupted hitler power
corrupted stalin
after he gained power and the same with
putin when putin gained power in 2000 do
you think
the amount of power that he was in
possession was for many years
do you think that corrupted him i mean
we're joking about dictators get the job
done
there is some sense in certain countries
where dictator is
the only thing that can stabilize a
nation
the the counter argument to that for
democracies
is like yeah but that's a short-term
solution for a long-term problem
so you want to embrace chaos of
democracy that might be violent
there might be a lot of uh just
constant changing of leadership there
might be a lot of corruption in the
short term but
if you stay strong with um
with the ideals of democracy then you'll
be uh ultimately create something that
as beautiful and stable as the united
states
the the sad thing is is i don't know if
that
if history tells that story it's like i
said you look at greece you look at rome
democracy kind of failed
the majority of rome the the most
successful empire
uh that we've had um was a dictatorship
for most of its
run so um but i do believe in a republic
which is sort of a limited democracy i
do believe
in in what we have here i believe in
common law i believe
um you know in individual rights um
but yeah i think you said it i think i
couldn't nobody could have said it
better yeah it's
it's a short-term solution you look at
saddam hussein
he kind of you know when we took took
him out then there was a lot of
infighting that
that happened that he was kind of
keeping at bay um
because uh he was a strong man dictator
well he's an interesting one inside to
interrupt
no from my understanding i'm sure people
correct me but
when saddam hussein first came to power
he was uh he's quite progressive
so like the dick the as far as i
understand
the signs of an evil dictator weren't
exactly there
so again there's i don't know if power
revealed the power corrupted
or that could have been the initial
subterfuge to kind of get everybody
you know hitler also is a you know
champion of the people let's build some
new roads
it's what psychopaths do and that's why
it's interesting to me i'm not sure if
power corrupts psychopaths
and now that we know that we can do
these cat scans and brain stands again
we know that they're born that way
power definitely corrupts people who
have
the capacity uh to feel and for empathy
power i'm not sure i don't think power
corrupts people who were born
uh psychopathic with that condition or
sociopaths who had
who you know who were closer to
psychopath and then had some traumatic
life you know i just think um you know
the best way to get away with whatever
nefarious thing you want to do to feel i
guess the only thing psychopaths can
feel is that excitement
is to pretend to be the opposite of what
you are yeah that's what that's what
killers do that's what the worst people
look at bill cosby i mean he was
what better way to hide you know
it's like what wokeness is now it's like
i'm such a great person and
you're like arya it's a great the best
way to hide
is to pretend to be the opposite of what
you are just like ted bundy i'm i'm just
an innocent
helpful guy and then boom next thing you
know you're getting your titbit off
that's really well said it's actually
kind of funny because i talk about love
a lot
and i think the people that kind of look
at me with squinty eyes
they wonder like how many bodies are in
that closet
you know what i mean like there's
something about the duality of like
we're so skeptical as a culture like if
somebody's just like
seems to be kind of sort of uh
i don't know positive and all that kind
of you know
how do i put it just simple uh simple
minded
in the positivity they express they
think like
okay there's some demons in there yeah
especially if you're a new yorker we
don't trust any the nicer you are the
more skeptical we are yeah
i've struggled with that down here i've
been like what's your angle and they're
like nah dude just
i wanted to show you the best tacos man
and i'm like did you really what do you
want
because in new york it's like if
anyone's nice to you they want something
yeah
and that's uh that's the the pro side to
that is it makes you very street smart
the
downside to that is it makes you way too
cynical yeah i
definitely experienced that here in
texas but people are super
super nice and they're like do all this
cool [ __ ] for you and
you wonder what what
what's the angle yeah what are we doing
here you mentioned
hyenas is your favorite animal i forgot
to ask you
what the hell were you thinking why is
hyena is your favorite animal
yeah it's um it's a fascinating animal
and
let's look at the whole animal kingdom
like why is that where do you put
so you like dogs love my favorite your
favorite is dogs
but they're kind of outside the animal
kingdom because you're thinking about
wolves
so the animal kingdom was in nature dogs
escaped nature they kind of did yeah
together with humans like in a
collaborative way
exactly so within nature within the
animal kingdom
what who's uh why not lions because
their lions are predictable
lions are just you know they're regal
and kind of like boring it's like the
hot chick
it's like we get it you were born the
best
yeah you know i like a scrappy by any
means necessary
intelligent and cunning uh but aren't
they dishonest
yeah and that's why i like them yes
they're dishonest they employ chicanery
they uh they're and that's just a sign
of how intelligent they are and how
self-reliant they are
and how brutal they are um they're
brutally honest
in how much they lie yeah you know
because it's just
they're trying to get the job done yeah
you know lions are just like
they're they're too gifted everyone
hates the [ __ ]
you know if i went to school with you
i'd like of course lex knows the [ __ ]
answer yeah lex was born smarter than me
yeah you know and you'd probably hate me
because i was the kid always seeking
attention and making people
it's like that's not interesting the guy
that claws his way to the top and those
are hyenas
they're also fascinating just by uh
merely who they are i mean they're not
related to any other animal they're
more closely related to cats than they
are dogs even though they look like this
dog yeah
they're but they're very like very
tangentially related even to cats
so they're their own kind of thing which
is kind of mysterious i don't think they
fully figured out
and uh they this pseudo penis thing is
the is the i mean
it is explain the pseudo penis yeah so
the
it's a matriarchal society by the way so
that's unique in and of itself
this we're talking about an apex
predator that is uh
matriarchal much like uh you know the
praying mantis it's very rare though
and they are [ __ ] brutal and vicious
and the women are bigger
and they let their cubs fight a lot of
fracture side and they do that because
they're like hey you're weaker they
let your brother kill you and uh the
women have penises
the women have pseudo penises that they
give birth out of and the birth is
violent
but they they roll around with just huge
pieces their glue guns are just [ __ ]
swinging
you know and the women are just run the
show and
uh it's just cool that they have these
pseudo penises
[Laughter]
uh it's almost romantic to eat this they
have the strongest bite force
they they pulverize bone like when they
eat an animal the animal's gone
there's no bones they eat everything
they can pulverize
their bite is so powerful they pulverize
bone and
eat it so if they consume an animal it
the animal was there and then the
animal's gone there's no
nothing for the vultures there to uh to
to grab
yeah i'm gonna have to revisit the
hyenas because my experience with the
heinous was
from uh first of all history hanging as
your show
uh has rebranded them for me but uh the
lion king
which is uh a cartoon i guess
that uh i get emotional at every time i
have a i hope i probably have father
issues
everyone every guy probably just you
just have feelings you're a good guy i
mean
everyone has that yeah yeah that one
gets everybody i don't know
i get i get every father-son movie like
blow with johnny depp
and uh ray liotta damn that's a good
movie
and whenever there's like um like the
disappointment in the father that his
son has become like
this incredibly successful drug lord
that then ends up with nothing
in in in prison uh just the sadness of
them communicating through letters man
that gets me every time
but but you know uh they're the hyenas
are not presented that well in that um
no they're usually portrayed as like uh
it's really
sad that they're portrayed that way and
lions like lions aren't dicks
lions are dicks they the the the
the alpha lions will kill the cubs of
another rival they do all types of dick
[ __ ] yeah and um yeah it's the
hyenas are more interesting like they'll
just roll in like a hyena will like
like you said the lie you know because
when you watch the serengeti
you know animals will hang out with each
other they're like by water
so one hyena will just kind of roll in
and pretend like it's not hungry and
then
bang they'll use any means necessarily
take an animal down
like lions will just use brute strength
hyenas
use cunning and you can even go on the
internet and find uh
memes of this where hyenas will grab the
big animal by the balls
and just like we'll sneak up behind it
and bite its balls and you'll watch an
animal ten size ten times the size of
the hyena just slowly
go down it's brutal but it's [ __ ]
hilarious
so i i think that's uh i don't know if
you uh followed the
the the channel um nature's medal
that that one weighs heavy on me um
with the hyenas on the balls i
it's tough to to intellectualize it it's
tough to think that
the entirety of life on earth has this
history of
predators being violent
just like just the murder that we come
from
yeah it's crazy it uh just like
we're talking about meditating on death
i actually i keep
following and unfollowing that instagram
channel because like sometimes
it's too much like i can't i can't
continue with the day after like seeing
the brutality the honest brutality of
that
i don't know how to make sense of it
it's important to acknowledge i think
because that it's real
we do come from that we are we evolve
from that
it's important we still do that we're
just hidden from it you know when you go
to the supermarket and get your slab of
meat
you know you're so disconnected from
where that meat came from
it came from that and often that's
uglier to watch
than because there's some honesty you
know the the the nature channels only
show
uh that's why we have so much sympathy
with the prey and this is where i think
the same thing with mafia movies they
don't show what the mafia really does
they glorify the good parts
that's why i like state of grace because
it's really just shaking down old people
and [ __ ] being dicks
it's not driving nice cars and being
like you know so and animal channels do
the same thing they only show when the
cheetah
gets it because that's that's the
exciting part but what most people don't
know
is that those predators strike out
almost always
a majority of the time the prey wins and
so
if you saw that and put in context you
might not hate it as much
when the predator actually gets the
little fawn or whatever
because it's so many fawns got away it's
so hard
to capture your prey and you know we we
don't have the the
they no no documentary is going to sit
around and show you
the 99 times the cheetah uh didn't catch
thank you for this perspective this
murder is difficult so like
this is the they never talk about for
people who murder
how difficult it is like it's tough to
trap somebody to convince them to come
back to your place
give it some respect put some respect on
ted bundy's name yeah it's not easy to
convince somebody to get in your
volkswagen beagle
and clean up and then you have to kind
of plan ahead because you want to keep
doing the murder mass murder you got to
learn how to saw them up
put them in duffel bags bury you gotta
learn a dig you gotta learn how to hide
you gotta learn the line i mean there's
a lot that goes into it
yeah that we need to put a little
respect on yeah yeah and you have to
figure out which tools work the best
for the song and all those kinds of
things um um so
thank you for the perspective that's
that's what i was hoping
will bring to this table uh before yeah
so you uh uh you got a little bit greek
in you
uh one of the episodes on
history hyenas you talked about the
battle of crete
where the greeks your people in uh
in 19 i guess 41 in the early stages of
the world war
ii is one of the most epic battles of
the war
in fact in 1941 in a speech made
at the reichstag hitler paid tribute to
the bravery of the greek saying
it must be said for the sake of
historical truth
that amongst all our opponents only the
greeks fought
with the endless courage and defiance of
death
so okay what do you make of this battle
what do you make of the spirit of the
greek people
this is one of the closest things to me
because my mother was
actually on the island of crete during
this
the first aerial invasion in history a
lot of people don't know that so this is
a very significant battle
um first time there was an invasion from
the sky
um and my mother was a little girl and
she lived through
four years of uh nazi occupation there
so my mother was a human rights lawyer
and everything but she just always hated
germans it's just what it is
she hated germans and she never got over
it so the most progressive open-minded
woman just could not get over this
um it's a monumental battle that a lot
of historians in retrospect have now
looked back on
and said because the nazis first off you
got to take it back to when
hitler instructed mussolini because
let's be honest mussolini was hitler's
[ __ ] you know what i mean it was like
if it were you know if it was fantasy
island hitler was the [ __ ]
and the and mussolini was boss to play
mussolini ever say no to hitler
or even maybe it's always like yes yes
yes we will do it and uh it's like it
takes
you have to take greece and so um
yeah so italy being
much bigger than greek greece is a tiny
country nine ten million
so italy invaded greece um
you know um and aki day is a big
it's a big holiday for greeks and this
speaks to the spirit
greeks in fight until we have a common
enemy
and then we unite you see it throughout
history sparta and athens
you see it in greek families where the
brothers will fight but then as soon as
we have a common enemy
we unite and maybe it's an overactive
brain we think too much our tradition's
philosophy
and we overthink things and we fight
with each other and take things
personally we're all so passionate
but when italy said hey we're gonna move
troops through
you know uh greek said aki which means
no and that was um
and then italy attacked and uh
we beat the [ __ ] out of them a much
bigger country
much uh more well-equipped country
greece beat the [ __ ] of them kicked them
back into albania actually
not only repelled them actually like
conquered some ground in albania and
pushed them back
and then hitler was like [ __ ] you know i
was planning my march to russia
uh but i have to go down because he
basically said to mussolini like you
know you
basically [ __ ] laughed i'm like afraid
i'm like i gotta do this myself because
you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
so then the nazis invaded greece
obviously they took the mainland with
fight and shot out the greeks never give
credit to the british in new zealand and
australian troops that were there
you know they were a large part of this
the majority of it
but the greeks fight dude civilians i
mean
they fought you know the ottomans were
there 400 years you go to greece now
there's no evidence there's
virtually no evidence of them ever being
there
that's the greek spirit kick them out
and we kicked out hummus too
so it's like your culture's gone you're
gone because greeks are
uh it's philotimo it's called philiptim
and it's a real thing filoptimo is uh
there's very little trans you can't
translate it but it's kind of like
honor loyalty friendship
uh altruism it's uh it's you can't
define it but greeks know it and we're
taught it from our from our uh
families it's a vibe and it's a greek
cultural thing
and we're an old culture and philotimo
is what it's called
and it's it's love it's passion
and it comes out and it comes out and so
um so hitler had to postpone his
invasion
of um of russia went down
the island of crete took 10 days to
conquer
it's an island to put that in
perspective the country of
france fell in three or four days i
can't even remember because they [ __ ]
just rolled over so what is it
what does a couple hours matter when
you're that much of a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
okay
what is a couple hours 12 hour [ __ ]
three or four days
the island of crete yeah took the
germans
10 days to conquer and because of that
and because of the greek resistance
hitler had to postpone his invasion
of russia to win her and of course that
was you know
that was his downfall just as it was
napoleons and
never dude never try to invade russia
they got millions of people to throw at
death
every time you read about russians in
history books like and a million died
i mean it's like you just guys throw
millions of people at the problem
and don't [ __ ] with that russian winner
and don't [ __ ] with russian people dude
they're tough
people in new york know that you don't
go to [ __ ] sheeps that man start
talking [ __ ]
you'll end up in a [ __ ] car trunk and
they'll brutally murder you i do not
[ __ ] with russians
amen and then there's i mean there's a
lot of people
a lot of historians argue that that
battle was because of the
russian winter because of delaying the
russian invasion but also
psychologically delaying the invasion
it was the first time i think it was the
first time the germans
failed not or didn't succeed like they
wanted to
early in the war which is a little like
psychologically the impact of that i
think is immeasurable
and also a lot of people argue from a
military
strategy perspective that the
just like you said it was an aerial
attack and that
hitler didn't think that that that
kind of attack would then be useful for
the rest of the war
so that's that's a really part where
whereas it might have been very
useful so it's uh it's really
interesting how these little battles can
steer the directions of war of course
me growing up in the soviet union we
didn't hear much about this battle
uh just like you said millions of
soviets died all those
people in history that you read about
dying those are all civilians but i mean
not all
but a very large number of them are
civilians and their stories
obviously that's the rooted the
literature the poetry the music
just the way people talk the way they
drink vodka the way they love
the way they hate the way they fear
that's all like rooted in world war
ii and world war one and so
but we never kind of think about
europe and we certainly grown up didn't
think about their role in the united
states
all this there's plenty of stories of
heroism in uh in the soviet union
enough enough for many lifetimes so but
it was fascinating to read from a greek
perspective
um because i you know i don't have many
greek friends
i'm hoping to change that uh
this is the beginning of a love affair
of your people
uh yeah likewise the americans don't
hear about the
soviet contribution to the end of world
war ii because obviously we became
you know enemies after that because of
the two systems but
yeah without the russians with world war
ii wouldn't have been one either
yeah the stories are written by the
victors that's really interesting i i
just looking at the at history you
wonder what's
missing i'll tell you what's missing
that i know for a fact
because my dad told my dad uh told me
combat's hell and he would tell me the
reality of what it's really like guys
pissing themselves calling for their
mother
the the fog of war obviously fracture
side happens all the time it's
pandemonium
i mean there's skill involved but i mean
there's no like it's a lot of that it's
just luck my dad said he my dad won
three
he got you know medals brea purple
hearts all that [ __ ]
and he said the reason was because he
can't he always said there's another
thing he told me you can't pin a medal
on a dead guy
so it's like those are the guys who
deserve it but you can't pin a medal you
can't
do the pomp and with and um i'll tell
you one thing
is that uh it is written by the victors
and all these leaders they say were in
the front were not in the front
we're not whenever the history books say
he led his troops into battle it's like
did he really
did he then how did he live because they
put like kids in the front you know it's
like
nobody limps back from the front with
like a injury you know that's
that's army pr you know whenever you
read
uh you know if uh 27 soldiers died 14
were
injured the word injured is pr that's
like
injured was he did he sprain his ankle
did he need
did he get carried off the court or you
know he was maimed
i mean he was like his leg was blown up
you know it's like
so uh i think that you know alexander
the great was just kind of in the back
on his horse and just kind of he had his
eunuch bloom a few times and he was like
is it bad up there
and then like after that he was like
okay with my scribe give me my scribe
okay when you write this down can you
put me in the front
yeah and i was just making me a big hero
and i was in there and then
you know he just blew his you know he
had sex with his eunuch and rode off
into the sunset
because there's just no way you survived
in the front especially warfare back
then
i mean it's like brutal then again you
have like uh
genghis khan the sense i got that he was
a little bit
up on the front at least the first yeah
or is that also
is he a little bit alex give me my
scribe yeah it's all lore i mean you
ever play the game of telephone
you know it's like you know there's no
video cameras back then so [ __ ] just get
turns into myth you know and uh there's
no way he was in the front
there's no way he wouldn't have lived
you know he was probably
good on horseback because those those
dudes were good on horseback but
it was like game of thrones back then
you had all these different people and
they kind of
yeah the the the mongols were wild dude
they are actually said like um
they started like they were more
adaptable to the horse because they were
so good on horseback that
kids started to be born like kind of bow
legged like to fit the horse it's wild
and they would
stretch their heads and [ __ ] like that
they'd wrap them and stretch their head
so they find like mongol
skulls and they look like cone heads and
they were
brutal and vicious then they would
maraude and rape and
all the fun stuff that you know when you
know when you visit other places back
then there's no tchotchke stops and
souvenir shops what you do is you take
women
and those are the tokens you know you
burn a few huts
different tourism was different back
then
yeah that's another difficult thing just
we're talking about nature and predators
to think about
the long stretch of history where it was
just murder yeah
and we made so much progress i guess
in the past couple of centuries the
united states is a shiny example of that
but do you think also that it's that
effect that we would
a lot of good things had to happen too
or else we wouldn't be here
so do we just focus isn't it like a car
crash effect
that like we're you know and the the
rubber neck who everyone pulls over to
see a car crasher are we just only
focusing on the negative things of
history because they're just more
exciting to us
like it's just not it's boring to be
like yeah and then there was a bunch of
villagers and they ate every day and
danced and loved yeah i wonder
i wonder how different those people were
you know like
they might have had the same exact loves
and fears and
like they were they perhaps had the same
kind of brilliant ideas in their head
if not more brilliant and we kind of
think about like this moment in history
is like the most special
moment like we're doing the coolest [ __ ]
but we're doing the most amazing
building the most amazing things but
maybe they were building amazing things
in their different way with like less
technological but in the space of ideas
in the space of just
all the different the camaraderie and
the space of um
like concepts uh mathematics all those
kinds of things
yeah i mean greece you look at the
architecture it still stands up i mean
all the government played still
arguably i mean as far as objective
beauty it's hard to argue that
greco-roman
it's just something about it with the
with the columns it's just
it's powerful it's i don't know even ayn
rand would probably appreciate it
she doesn't no no no
[Laughter]
so in your history hyenas that
unfortunately has come to an end yeah
we're talking about empires coming to an
end all empires fall yeah
um that one um oh it may rise again
empires might rise who knows who knows i
i'm obviously a fan so i hope it does
rise again
but you've uh seemed to develop your own
language
can you uh you know it's what it is
what is what is that what the hell um
is this some kind of medical condition
or can you can you
explain like the linguistic essentials
that uh
catch us up to the linguistic essentials
that people need to know
to understand the way you speak you ever
you know leopold and loeb you know the
story of those two
uh they murdered that kid and they had
this weird relationship
uh anyway it's an interesting thing to
google leopold and love these two guys
who ended up murdering a kid because
they developed their own language with
each other and uh this whole reality and
this
weird thing and they wanted to know what
it's like to murder a kid in a murder
kid it's a famous story in american
lore and history whatever famous case
um but this phenomenon yeah me and chris
got together
it wasn't as dark as leopold though we
didn't murder a kid but
we murdered a podcast
or at least stab it a few times yeah
it's um it was something in
the organic chemistry of me and chris
that i think we'll both
end up appreciating even probably more
than we do now
that uh it's mysterious i gotta be
honest with you
it's um it was the thing that
it wasn't conscious uh wasn't
intentional
it was something that happened in the
music of our energies
yeah that just went it's fascinating
like when you hear someone sing or
when a jazz band hits a rhythm or even
when i'm on stage and i just
catch a rhythm it's like dude i didn't
make a choice there i don't know what
that is i don't know how to explain it
but it comes from somewhere else and uh
i don't know what it is
it's beyond my comprehension but with
chris
uh there was this magical chemistry that
uh you know i have chemistry with a lot
of people
and uh it can be funny and i feel zero
chemistry here this is great
yeah it's a little bit more intelligent
than what me and chris did
uh but you know uh me and chris uh i
think we connected
in on the funny bone like i he i found
him so
funny and we found the same things funny
and from that
these organic expressions came from the
some part of our brains
that was created from this chemistry and
yeah we just developed this in
language in this cult following and
people were really upset
when we ended but it was the right thing
to end because
like all things that end it was kind of
done a few episodes even before we
finished and
i think we pulled the plug before it
started rolling downhill
like all uh you know like all great
flings you know there's a long
relationship
long marriages are boring and
comfortable
the one you really like [ __ ] always
ends abruptly and sadly and uh but you
always look back and you jerk off to it
and uh but so you guys made love we made
yeah so it's like it was like a hot
fling
with me and him and it was intense and
we
burned the candle at both ends and it
was me i think
that podcast was meant to be three years
and um maybe people will go back and
appreciate it and
listen to it over and over again and i
think the new things we do people will
love i
i'm doing long days now that podcast and
people seem to enjoy it i'm really
enjoying the long days yeah yeah on
youtube
i just found myself just like staring it
at you uh ranting for same with tim
dillon i really enjoyed the whatever
those rants are the genius of just
one thing after the other but definitely
the chemistry
almost as a study i remember the reason
i first started listening to it i was
trying to get
an a perspective on certain historical
moments
like it was interesting i tuned in to
learn history
yeah i came for the history and like
stayed for the
the chaos and crack open and clean out
and yeah this it was almost i listened
to rogan
like this sometimes i'll i'll re-listen
to an episode
uh to to try to understand why was this
so fun to listen to
it's it's almost like trying to analyze
humor or something like that but
it's nice from from a conversational
perspective like why was this so easy to
listen to
and then and uh with history hyena is
like why is the chemistry so good
it's it's so it's weird it's weird
uh because there's not many podcasts
like i don't know any
with chemistry like that yeah it's
interesting and it's kind of sad
that uh that that uh the the fling
or the prostitute in vegas has to end
you know
like that but that's what makes it
special it's the bokowski thing with the
fog
the the british office one of my
favorite shows was
was that it ended very quick you know
it's only a couple seasons or something
like that
and that was tragic but that took guts
to just end it
given all the money you could have made
given all the you just end it and that's
what makes it like truly special
yeah and i'll tell you man i'll just
emphasize it because i marvel at it too
um because as a guy who tries to always
figure out
uh what the causes of things i gotta be
honest man looking back on that even
with retrospective wisdom you know that
2020 hindsight we've been done a couple
months now
it's um it's something that i can't
explain
yeah it's something that i don't know
how you quantify it i don't know how you
describe it
it's it's musical it's really kind of
rhythmic
so maybe uh maybe like a netflix show
about history
that's that's another that that's in the
future
with the two of you yeah who knows you
guys will meet like
uh with that the way you meet with the
fling like
a decade from now at a diner and uh
you're both way fatter and uglier and
then you just reminisce
over some cigarettes and coffee that
could be yeah it could be
yeah but it's definitely a classic
podcast that people can go back and
appreciate it's fast-paced and
it was unique what was it like to
research for uh
i mean it was really scholarly the the
depth of research that you performed
it sometimes felt like you almost read
an entire wikipedia
article beforehand
or like exactly true uh we were we were
one fan we attracted such
funny people to that podcast and the
fans were so funny
and one fan called us nicknamed those
wikipedia [ __ ]
and so it just stuck yeah we just would
read wikipedia i would do a lot more
research to chris
yeah and uh so i would actually uh you
know once in a while he'd get into it
too but
for very interesting episodes i got some
some
some subject matter would just pull me
in like bernie madoff just to think of
one that was recent it was one of our
last ones and i think one of our better
episodes
and i'm glad that uh it kind of ended
after that because it was rare that
i think we started to slip a little bit
um i got fascinated and i got i did a
lot of research for bernie madoff but
usually yeah we'd pull up wikipedia and
we'd have fun we were sort of the
antithesis of dan carlin i mean you went
to dan carlin
for uh accuracy and thoughtfulness and
you went to us
for it was a hang with history that's
why history hyenas was such an
appropriate name
because it was it was a little bit of
his some some episodes were more hyena
more wild and a little history and some
were a little more dense like the battle
of crete and less hyena so
you were you were always going to get
both you're either going to get a
majority of one or the other yeah and
dan carl is the lion i guess
yeah and uh you guys look pretty
predictably good
uh i mean what what are your thoughts
about i mean he's a storyteller too he
gets a lot of criticism for the
from the historians quote-unquote that's
why he likes to knock
he keeps saying he's not a historian but
what's your um
what are your thoughts about uh hardcore
history with dan carlin like was he an
inspiration to
the podcast you were doing uh or
or like an account like uh almost like
reverse psychology inspiration
where you wanted to do some kind of
opposing type of podcast in history
or was history always just like a
a launching pad to just talk [ __ ] about
human nature
more the latter i wasn't even aware of
his podcast when we started oh
interesting yeah and uh
so we it was just very organic again
like the chemistry me and chris
became very good friends we started the
podcast
first we did a web series called bay
ridge boys which has its sort of little
cult following he did like five episodes
and ended it
um and then we did the podcast and uh
hyenas were my favorite animal
and i talked about them passionately and
i told chris about them and then he
started appreciating him and we both
loved history i majored in history it's
one of the things i love i go to museums
all the time i go to his i do history
tours so does he
and so it was just sort of a natural
let's do a history podcast and it gave
us something to talk about each episode
to sort of lean our you know hang our
hats on and
riff off of so it had nothing to do with
dan's what i think about dan's i think
it's great
i think even if he's inaccurate uh in
the opinions of the historical community
it starts conversations
which is good it's like this thing where
people go oh it's dangerous rhetoric
it's like no
rhetoric only becomes dangerous when
education fails what's going on in
america is education has failed
so if you call someone online dangerous
it's not him that's dangerous
it's the [ __ ] stupid people that's
dangerous and it's the fault of this
country we didn't listen to aristotle
the future of a civilization depends on
public education
yeah and we failed education has failed
kids are kids are not interested in [ __ ]
and um so in some sense those uh like
dan's podcasts and
podcasts can be incredibly educational
that's he's uh
the storytelling that pulls you in
ultimately leads to you internalizing
these stories and like remembering them
and and
thinking through them and all those
kinds of things that is much more
powerful than any
book on history that's accurate i think
often it inspires you to go learn more
so it's like i know we did that i mean
you know i people would go hey i went
and learned about this because they knew
with us there was no pretense which was
great
that we had no standard so it's like
nobody came to us for historical
accuracy
but i was kind of turned on by the fact
that it
inspired people to go learn about this
stuff or to at least know like battle of
crete like you said a very
underappreciated battle um even winston
churchill said uh from here on we will
no longer say
that uh greeks fight like heroes but
heroes fight like greeks i mean it was a
monumental battle and um you know not
talked about enough and
i i i our podcast would inspire people
to go actually learn
more to go listen to dan carlin or to go
pick up a book or
to do research on their own and so i
think podcasts dan carlin's obviously
much more accurate than us but
it's good that people are going to
podcast like yours and
to learn [ __ ] joe was is really like
the progenitor of that i mean you know
having intellectuals on
and getting the public interested with
this new medium
um in in people who are intelligent
it's nice because you know what the
mainstream press pushes out is horseshit
gorgeous horseshit it's got a beautiful
veneer
but no substance and so this this is a
nice pushback
yeah the authenticity of joe's show i
mean i'm through i started listening
from the very beginning you know doing
my in grad school
you know i like a technical person and
he just pulled me in
and made me curious to learn about all
kinds of things
and use my own critical reasoning skills
on some of the
[ __ ] guests he's had and some of the
most inspiring guests he's had
so i'll teach you to think can you uh i
don't know much about bernie madoff as a
small tangent
can you tell me who the hell is bernie
man oh birdie madoff is the goat
the greatest thief of all time dude um
hedge fund guy ran a hedge fund and uh
pulled uh
stole the most money in the history of
america i mean a con artist
and um he just people obviously he's
become
he's a household name because of the
magnitude of his crime but you got to
appreciate again you got to appreciate
what went into this and how long he was
able to pull it off
uh by tricking the smartest and richest
people in the world
and a brilliant scam the con man uh con
man is
short for confidence man and it it came
from
yeah con men basically they they exude
confidence and they trick people
by playing on their ego and blind spots
and
uh the word comes from a guy i can't
remember where but what he used to do i
can't remember the guy's name and you
know whatever you can google it
con man but it's very interesting the
the first con man that
is on record what he would do it he
would go to very rich people and he'd be
very well dressed
right and he'd go he's i bet you you
don't have the confidence
to give me your watch and he would plan
the egos these very
powerful and rich people and they would
give him the watch for some reason some
sort of reverse psychology [ __ ]
and he'd take the watch and he would
just steal it
because basically saying like i don't
have the compass give him the watch
because you don't i don't know you don't
think i'm gonna give it back and he
would just take it yeah so bernie madoff
was a very sophistic sophisticated con
man
and again we were talking about people
pretending to be the opposite of what
they are
bernie hid his uh
thievery in how available he was to his
clients how he would show up at every
bar mitzvah every birthday he was always
available for their phone calls
and he uh played on their egos he made
it so people were wanted to invest in
him
like they were competing he made it very
exclusive he he wouldn't just take
anyone
and there was a method behind that
madness because he wanted the whales
that wouldn't notice that he was he was
had this pyramid scene going and so what
he would do is he would just rob from
the richer
and he'd just get it was like he'd pay
back the richer with the guy who was a
little
and it was a pyramid scheme and um he
was able to do it for so long and steal
so much money and he would win people
over with the scheme because with that
scheme he was the only guy who could
provide
who could guarantee like a one percent
return even during times of recession
and because he was such a good con man
he hijacked people's reasoning with his
charm
and that's what con artists do that's
what psychopaths do they're so [ __ ]
charming
they get in that volkswagen beetle
because if they use their reasoning for
one second they'd go hey
nobody can provide one percent returns
during recessions how the [ __ ] is this
guy doing it i'll tell you how he's
doing it
he's stealing from another guy to pay
you you [ __ ] idiot
so charisma is essential to you maybe
you can
help explain something to me something i
have been
affected by way too loud for your
listeners there's gonna be comments like
tell this guy to calm down i'm sorry i'm
greek a positive
yeah no that's beautiful i love it
something that i have been thinking
about and have encountered indirectly is
jeffrey epstein
and i have a sense because of mit
because of all the other
people that have been uh touched the
wrong term by jeffrey epstein in the
sense that
literally literally and figuratively
yeah
and it always felt to me like there's
not
a deep conspiracy i don't know i don't
know
but it felt to me like it's not
something deeply rooted conspiracy
where like eric weinstein thinks that
there's some probability that uh that uh
jeffrey epstein
is a front for like an intelligent
agency whether it's israeli or
uh the cia i don't know but is a front
for something much much bigger
and then i always thought that he's just
maybe you can correct me but more of the
bernie madoff variety
where he's just a charismatic guy who
uh maybe a psychopathic in some sense so
you know also a pedophile but just
charismatic and is able to convince
people of that one percent of any idea
that uh in in the case of scientists is
able to convince
these people that their ideas matter
uh so one thing scientists don't really
you know
despite what people say i don't think
they care about money as much as people
think
i mean people are ridiculous when they
think that yeah that's why people get
into science for the money yeah right
the personalized against science are
obsessed with minutia and when they
they do the scientific method you know
how boring that is like you
have to have a love for it yeah exactly
in order to do it but the thing
true what drives you is for your ideas
to be then heard
and when uh when a rich guy comes over
probably super charismatic
is going to tell you that your ideas
especially so for some of these
outsiders at mit
at harvard and caltech all these like uh
sort of uh big scien like
physics biology artificial intelligence
computing
fields to hear somebody say that your
ideas
are brilliant and ideas matter it's
pretty powerful especially when you've
been
an outsider like he's talked to a bunch
of people who were
who had outsider ideas you know the
the the the big negative for me of
modern academia is that
most people actually like most
communities most people think the same
and there's
just these brilliant outsiders and the
outsiders are just
uh derided and so when you have jeffrey
epstein
like a hyena sorry sorry sorry
uh going from on the outside and picking
off these brilliant minds that are the
outsiders
you can use charisma to convince them to
uh
to to collaborate with him to take his
funding and then
thereby he builds a reputation like uh
slowly accumulates these people that
actually results in
a network of like some of the most
brilliant people in the world
you know and then pulls in people like
bill gates and i don't know
political figures i tend to believe that
one
one person can do that yeah i mean look
at hitler
charisma is blinding i think that's what
con man
speaking of bernie madoff that's one of
their major tools
is flattery glib superficial charm
it creates those blind spots people want
to hear how great they are they want to
be flattered it it takes your defenses
down
plays to our ego the the how much we're
all just pieces of garbage and want to
hear how great we are
we want that love from our mother and
our father it's freudian and
and they know because they're not
burdened with that need
they're not burdened with that uh
empathy or emotions and they just see
things very calculatively
um they play they know that we're prey
in their game
and they use that against us and that is
why someone
who is not that intelligent like hitler
can probably convince a lot more
intelligent people
you know and that's why we can't give
him dylan power because
you know he already stands on a stage i
mean if we let that guy i mean he will
just take over a country and everyone
who can't cook well will be eliminated
yeah
so it's like i wonder why he keeps
complimenting me when we're in private
exactly be careful
he looks at me just your your i like
your suit i like the cut of your
jib yeah definitely i wouldn't be
careful that kid he's hitler
but it's crazy to me clip that please
the internet i mean but i mean quentin
tarantino said it to bed i mean
in his grip personality goes a long way
dude yeah i mean personality
can can usurp common sense and reason of
the smartest people these
absolute smartest people can be
hypnotized
it's sort of like a sexy woman it's like
you can just it just
you can be tricked because we have such
a blind spot for uh
you know for uh for flattery yeah i
wonder
i think there's a bbc documentary on uh
i think it's called something like
charisma
hitler's charisma or something like that
just quite i mean that one focused more
about
the power of the speeches but i wonder
if
most of the success or the rise of
hitler and the third reich had to do
with the
charisma of hitler when he's alone in a
room with somebody with the generals
just one-on-one like i wonder i wonder
if that's the essential element
of just being able to just look into a
person's eyes
like flatter them or whatever is needed
right to earn their
trust and then convince them of anything
you want
right yeah i mean you're right because
that's that's the one piece of history
we don't have i don't know
we don't know we do know that the kid
crushed
i mean he was a headliner he got up
there and his phone
would flop around i mean he crushed it
yeah there's certain elements about
nationalism and pride that are really
powerful like
a lot of us uh humans i think long for
that
for the feeling of belonging and when
some charismatic leader
makes us feel like we belong to a group
the uh the amount of evil we can do to
other humans because of that
especially nobody wants to look and
nobody wants to do the work to be better
or look at where they messed up why does
it always have to be the jews that are
you know it's like get over it guys
i mean it's like they killed jesus you
get over it yeah okay it's a long time
ago i mean move on
i'm jewish i understand because we do
run the central banks and
and the weather and the weather yeah
don't forget about the weather that's a
big one that's a funny one that people
created like who gives
what is the weather like what's the
importance of the weather all right the
jews made it rain outside good you gotta
[ __ ] you know they made it snow okay you
get a day off thank you jews
yeah it's like yeah there's certain
conspiracies that make me like flat
earth
like what what's the motive like what
who what's the motivation
for lying that the earth is round like
what's the conspiracy yeah what does
anyone get out of it yeah what is
exactly the
profit what's what's the what's the
strategy
uh do you have any from a historical
perspective or just a human perspective
conspiracy theories you connect with or
you're not necessarily conspiratorial
i'm uh i'm not necessarily
conspiratorial
um nobody cares that much um but they're
but then you know what happens is you
find out this one or this two
uh and you start questioning everything
and you start questioning everything man
it's like you know the vietnam war
started that was a lie
um that was a false flag and then next
thing you know everything's a false flag
there are some strange things on 911
um you know there's some strange things
from a scientific perspective i'm no
scientist but it's like
you know yeah three steel framed uh
skyscrapers falling
on the same day in the same way a lot of
people
say oh it was they were hit by planes
it's like yeah but that's not where they
fell they fell because of fires
and usually not usually
all the time except for three times and
there was buildings that have burned for
longer than that um
and there might be good explanations but
the lack of transparency
it's like i feel like government and
building seven's weird i mean the way it
kind of died just a neat
just a neat the physical i mean you're a
scientist
is that well i don't i i has their
resistance from the steel and so
no is it in the free fall not all
scientists know everything i'm
just a computer guy okay because i had
some questions i wanted to ask you
about my biology but yeah so exactly i
don't understand biology i don't
understand
the melting point of steel i don't but
i'm just a common sense human
that looks at government and
institutions when they try to
communicate
and there's a certain human element
where you
can sense that there's dishonesty going
on that dishonesty might not be deeply
rooted in a conspiracy theory and
something malevolent
it might just be rooted more likely to
me in a basic
fear of losing your job right so when
you have a bunch of people that are
afraid of losing their job
you know and they just don't want to
uh like the origins of the virus whether
it came from a labyrinth
or not you know that's a pretty i know a
lot of biologists behind
closed doors that that say it's very
likely it was leaked from
the lab right but like they don't want
to talk about it because there's not
good evidence either way
it's mostly you're just using common
sense so they're waiting for good
evidence to come out
in either direction but just like nobody
in positions of uh
institutional like centralized power
wants to just honestly say
we don't know or on the point of masks
or all those kinds of things to say
you know here's the best evidence we
have we're not sure we're trying to
figure it out we're desperately trying
to figure that out or just like honesty
especially in the modern day that's the
hope i have for the 21st century is
people seem to detect [ __ ] much much
better because yeah internet
internet yeah yeah and we also believe
crazy [ __ ] too
there's no yang without a yang i guess
but the i think the conspiracy theories
arise only
when the people in positions of power
and government and institutions are full
of [ __ ]
like the error will be taken out of the
conspiracy theories if the people in
elected power would be much more honest
like just like real
you have people like andrew yang
whatever you think about him
just more honest he he just like says
whatever the hell
uh comes to mind by the way he's running
for new york
mayor there we go do you have opinions
yeah it's no good i like andrew yang and
it's no good
i i'll be honest with you i'm i'm a
lifelong new yorker i mean i'm a new
yorker
well you're in new york or so nothing's
good well something is good
okay and talking on let's be honest
about new york
yeah it's a very socially liberal place
it is the head of the snake
new york is the country if new york when
new york's not doing good countries not
doing good
um it's the most important city dc new
york
it's really rome be honest it's it's uh
i maybe i'm biased i don't know
no we just new yorkers we walk around
everywhere we go this is just like new
york but not new york
it's um but and new york needs and i'm a
guy who leans left i
you know i just i lean left and that's
just what it is a dictator
is that where you're going no we don't
like stalin we need it's a money town
let's be come on man i mean new york is
a money town
and uh wall street and then when aoc and
her
cronies um at the local level rejected
that amazon thing you're going like
what do you think makes cities and what
what's going to create jobs in the 21st
century what do we need
more nail salons more pizza places i
mean we're living in the tech revolution
and
you know whatever your opinions are
about jeff bezos
that's the world tech and they wants to
come here
of course you give them tax breaks
that's why any companies go anywhere
she's so [ __ ] utopian and that that
progressive wing is so utopian
and that always ends in disaster because
it's not rooted in reality
it doesn't accept the reality that
people are self-interested now they're
going to do this 14
15 tax hike on people making a million
dollars more in new york city a million
dollars is not that much
so people are gonna flee new york the
tax base is gonna flee
new york's gonna follow [ __ ] like it did
before so you're saying it basically
needs
a more capitalist front like
capitalistic type of thinker that
bloomberg
giuliani when he was still sane and his
hair wasn't melting off his face
prosecutor you need to talk i mean i
don't know what's happened that guy's
lost it
but it's fun yeah it's fun to watch yeah
it's fun to watch him be just like uh
trump's lacking like yeah boy whatever
you want boss i'll just say whatever you
want boys
uh new york is a money town that needs a
money guy and sort of more
of a republican i have to say on the
local level as more of a guy who leans
left i'll just be honest
it it's a tough city that needs a tough
mayor not some guy who's going like i
understand we all need free money
you know andrew yang i think is right in
the big picture because all the
real jobs are somewhere else you look at
those asian cities you go like oh
that's what our cities used to look like
at the industrial revolution you know
there was like there was jobs and people
were making things here and
now you look at those cities in asia and
you're going like wow and then you go to
detroit and you're like
yeah we're done you go to cleveland you
go we we're done
so i i don't actually it's funny the the
reason i really like andrew yang is
i've learned a lot every time he talks
like it's not his opinions
he's just giving a lot of data yeah like
information which i
just start a podcast don't run for mayor
well yeah that's true he already has a
podcast i think
yang speaks who doesn't who doesn't
[ __ ] who does it now
that's the way we communicate i don't
even talk to people unless it's on a box
what listen man i'm a i'm not going to
criticize that because there is
something
like i talked to my dad on a podcast
for four hours and i'm not sure i
wouldn't i would ever talk to him
in the way we talked without the podcast
what does he do
uh physicist oh [ __ ] but like
yeah it's uh episode 100 and
you know
i uh the way i recorded that podcast is
i tried to put my ego aside it's
actually really tough to talk to your
dad
especially because you're giving him a
platform uh
especially so at that time this is
already a bit of a platform for this
podcast
and so there's this as a sun
you think like oh here it goes with this
[ __ ] again like that's the natural
sun thought
you have but at the same time i wanted
to
the way i thought about it is in 20
years when i look back like i want to do
a conversation where i'm
happy with it you know so i want to make
him shine
but i also called him on like why were
you so distant
like like all that kind of stuff yeah it
was very difficult to do but it was
really important to do and i don't think
i'd be able to do it without a
without a microphone right listen how
often do we sit there
and just focus our attention just look
at the other person
i i don't know man this is not even
recording right now
i just invited you over just so we could
actually you're right the podcast does
make like i listen i've been listening
to every word you've been saying and if
we weren't doing a podcast
i might be looking at my phone or being
self-conscious about something else or
you're nervous or excited
especially with people close to you i
mean that was i recommend that actually
for people
to talk to their family on a podcast
okay or like
fake or not that's really powerful uh
it made me realize that there's a clear
distinction between the conversations we
usually have with humans and those we
have
when the podcast is being recorded um
what the [ __ ] were we talking about
before that uh i knew you were gonna
lose your train of thought on that one
because
that's a big one there's a motion behind
that one a podcast with dad is gonna
take
that's gonna take you to a place i took
you to a place it took you outside
of interviewer new york place yeah
in new york and yang yeah so the data
one of the things that really surprised
me about
[Laughter]
i liked the psychoanalysis you just
threw in there
[ __ ] million people listening to this
14 rogans
isn't it enough dad i'm creating robots
is that enough for you
that's what drives you probably that's
probably what drives me that's what
gives meaning to life is it's never
enough
and uh i hope to pass that on to my kids
one day uh that nothing's ever enough
whether they're robot or human right
your kids most likely let's be honest
bro i call one of your robots
if you love your are you starting to
love your is it going to be like that
pygmalion thing you create them and then
they kill you but even while they're
killing you you got a tear right
here a slow one one tier one tear and
just yeah why are you doing this
frankenstein
why but i loved you those would be the
last words out of my mouth
uh but andrew yang mentioned something
on um
that it cost uh four hundred thousand
dollars
over four hundred thousand dollars per
year to support
one person in prison in new york
like when i heard that number it was
really confusing to me
like that it cost that much 400k per
person
and it was really refreshing to hear a
politician
describe a particular problem with data
that this is
this prison industrial complex whatever
the hell it is
and whether the solution it's unclear
what the solution is i think he has
solutions but just the honesty of
presenting that information
was refreshing and i'm not sure a
capitalistic
person would solve that those kinds of
problems he might make worse
and i'm not you know i'm a huge fan of
capitalism
i think i think the free market
is is the way we make progress in this
world but it
seems to go wrong in certain directions
like the military-industrial complex the
prison
anything that ends with industrial
complex
and so i'm i'm not sure i'm not sure if
all of the problems you're basically
saying
let's put new york's problems aside
we need to have new york shine first to
do what it does best
essentially yeah and then the problems
will fix them well
and then we can focus on the problems
but if you just say like here's a
problem here's the problem here's a
problem
let's make sure we have the safety net
that protects against all these kinds of
problems that's not going to
that's going to kill the city the spirit
of the uh of the city
that is in your biased opinion the rome
of the world
that said a lot of people are fleeing
new york yeah that that's why i say it
uh that's the reality of the situation
is you know
um i i'm all for the public good but
yeah there needs to be
back to that greek expression pon metro
narstan i i also
think the free market is responsible for
progress i think it's the most natural
thing the thing that's most aligned with
human nature which is self-interest
and um which i believe not to the extent
that iran would but i do believe people
are mostly self-interested
especially with one gun to the head um
morals are out the window
you know it's about survival so you know
create a system
that respects that and acknowledges that
but socialism works very well
at least right now as a check as to
temper
uh the excesses of capitalism and in
certain scenarios
is uh the more appropriate system you
know in a vacuum so one being
prisons or you know uh you know
governance uh you know uh maybe even
well
and this is a difficult one but in
health care health care
it's unclear what's right there's a lot
of debates there yeah doctors want boats
so i guess you're voting for aoc you're
saying but no i'm not vote for issue but
i do
it's just a tough one that's a tough one
but ultimately
the hippocratic oath it's like how do
you turn people away man how do you do
that to people it's like
it's it's a tough thing to uh
to reconcile helping people curing
people with
the uh the marketplace it's just i can
understand why that one's so tough
and then you got hypochondriacs of
course who drain the system you know
like people who are
have anxiety like me who had coveted
called 14
uh you know i called 14 ambulances so
and then of course we're fat and the
free market made us fat because it
played
the marketing made us want all this junk
food and that's a burden on the health
care system so we got to do something
about that we got to get creative we
need new thinkers i'll be one of them
when you go to a fast food restaurant
you stand on a scale if you're over a
certain thing
you can't be served it's good for the
health care system
you know you just hand it a salad and
say sorry this burger's illegal for
right now if you achieve these certain
uh bmi goals
then you can you can have this burger
but right now
you can that's where the state's
important yeah okay to regulate our
freedoms no slurpees i'm with you
bloomberg
well i'm with you to go along i think
the salads are too expensive they should
be subsidized if you
if you go to like a fast food joint uh
the burger is always going to be cheaper
than the salad yeah
and this does not make sense we should
run this platform delicious i'll be your
vice president
we'll ban burgers for uh for people over
a certain way
and make salads cheap three-day work
weeks why has that wait wait
okay where are you going with this one
good good for the economy
stimulates the economy right more shifts
it creates more jobs
more people spending because they have
more leisure time boosts the leisure
economy
you know why are we still doing the
five-day work week that that was
that was tempered from the seven-day
work week that was so the seventh it
used to be seven day work
it used to be like and people who were
just these libertarians like come on
dude
what is this fresh are we freshman in
college yeah you're gonna you
we're gonna talk about iron ran next
like let's talk about reality okay and
human nature people are [ __ ] greedy
they're they lie they you know there's
no end to up which is one of my favorite
expressions
um no center up no end to up there's no
in top but can we dissect that yeah from
a randian perspective
there's no end to up which is uh you
just keep going it's never enough
oh never enough no it's never enough no
end to up more more
more and you know you have to reconcile
your fact that you're going to die so
like there's no end up thing is that
balance is is just
as valuable as
progress so we have to reconcile those
two things and put them
on a seesaw and figure out how to get
two people who have the
equal weight to to keep it like that and
that's the goal and it constantly
vacillates
uh according to the time you sometimes
you need a little more socialism
sometimes you need a little more
capitalism
you gotta you gotta you gotta fly the
plane man you gotta fly the plane dude
what's your um looking back at history
hyenas
is there a moment time period in history
a person in history
that's most fascinating to you you
mentioned bernie madoff maybe he's
second to birth made up
is there in a battle of crete is there
something that you've always been
curious about even if it's something you
haven't actually researched that well
yet
just something that pulled your
curiosity that uh instructed the way you
think about the world
an individual or an event or an event
individual
uh you know yeah moment in history
or person in history um
there's a few but uh you know queen
elizabeth uh the elizabethan
era you know the sun never sets in the
british empire
very successful empire uh
what an absolute success story that is
for a leader and a woman um
can you tell a little bit about her
story well i actually don't know much
about the bridge yeah she had a good run
i think it's like 70 years you know
there's a shakespeare
the you know the oh i guess what's the
word pax romana the the
period of rome that was at peace and
they flourished like a couple of
emperors like trajan or some good ones
and i think he was part of the pox
romana that
sort of just a peace and a comfortable
flourishing time and england
had sort of that in their empire under
her successful range she murdered her
cousin she
you know the movies this is that you
know um kate blanchett plays her
and and does so and she didn't win the
oscar because [ __ ] gwyneth paltrow
put a put a british accent on in
shakespeare in love it's a tragedy why
do i know this
because i'm not a full man i'm a
comedian which means i do skits and i
perform
um and i uh cate blanchett's incredible
actress great movies
she was just so and here's the thing she
she never got married she was oh she was
so
um astute at public relations
and and and imagine how strong you got
to be as a woman to lead
the greatest empire maybe known to man
at the time and to do so
so successfully how machiavellian you
have to be how idealist you have to be
how much of a good marketer you have to
be
propaganda machine was on point she was
married to england
she was adored the way she adorned
herself
you walked in you're like holy man god
just walked in here
and of course she got [ __ ] i mean who
doesn't [ __ ]
we all [ __ ] even robots one day will
[ __ ] yeah but she was
she she did that propaganda thing and
historians aren't
uh haven't they haven't decided this but
i believe
she [ __ ] and i believe she did that as
a
tool of propaganda i'm married to
england
so you oh you're directly referring to
like using sex as a way to manipulate
people
well she her she was known as like the
the virgin queen
and uh and her thing was like i'm
married to england like i can't be
distracted by
man a woman she never had any kids
nothing i think she did that as a tool
of manipulation yes which you need yeah
rulers need to you know obama made you
feel good and then he went
carpet bombed everywhere you need to
feel good
about your guy no matter how evil they
are and she was [ __ ]
a dictator but when you look back at her
everyone's like oh my god she was so
great
the horror and the [ __ ] that she had to
do she didn't put that in the history
books
but that's what probably was part of
what made her successful
and um she's a fascinating character to
to ponder him because she was so
successful and
and and england flourished so much
and uh it's just fascinating to me
because she was the great virgin queen
and
can you think of a there's no other
woman who was that say i mean angela
merkel i mean come on
yeah i mean there's nobody who comes
close and
defeating the spanish armada i think
that happened under her i mean i'm no
professionalist but i mean the woman
crushed
and uh do you think it's more effective
to lead by
love which just sounds like what she did
from the pr perspective or by fear
where where do you land on that would
not give out peter that's a great
question
um i'm not we gotta ask joe
well yeah this is interesting because i
think leading in the 21st century in
whatever ways
is different i think it's very difficult
to lead by fear
i mean i'm that's why i i find putin
fascinating
and like really fascinating
like is he a relic of another era
or is he something that will still be
necessary in the coming decades for
certain nations
i think he's a i don't think he's a
relic from another era i think his
background
i think he is who you think he is
because his background was an espionage
his background was in subterfuge and
espionage i think i've said the word
subdivision maybe 10 times now
but he uh you like big words
intellectuals i just
i'm sitting here with you it's my it's
time to flex
um but he um he's very good at that
right like uh
controlling people with psychology and
even if you look at the way he's sort of
used the internet
and um has sort of been you know gotten
in
to the citizens of other countries
opinions and
it's very kgb he also looks great
without a shirt on a pony
on a horse on a horse yeah yeah
i thought he would choose a pony because
a pony's smaller would uh would you
would you put queen elizabeth as the
greatest leader of all time probably
yeah i think as a woman and you look at
uh
you look at the the length of the rain i
think it's like 70 something years or
something like that with that she
reigned success man success she used the
church she used public psychology
shakespeare the greatest playwright of
all time
uh under her reign you know people were
going to plays
and uh it was it was a successful run
and she was marauding everywhere else
marauding and and culling resources for
the empire
just say uh absolute successful it's
even uh a token of her success we don't
consider her a dictator
yeah she's a dictator you know she was
queen i
this my thing i love about the feudal
system that these [ __ ] countries
still have feudal systems
they're celebrating a horrible thing
divine right of kings
oppression kings were dictators and now
they have [ __ ] ceremonial
why don't we have a ceremonial fuhrer
what is in germany
he doesn't do any of the bad stuff he
just rolls around and does legit
i mean it's like what the [ __ ] there's
no difference between a hitler and a
[ __ ] king they did the same
horrible [ __ ] why not a [ __ ]
ceremonial conqueror
alexander the great walks in rapes a
little bit but it's all fun it's for
ceremony
he represents the country macedonia
it's interesting to see that uh
some you're starting to see a bit of
that in russia with stalin
actually the celebration of of a man
that helped
win the great patriotic war uh-oh yeah
right so like you you're already
starting to see that it's very possible
in history books you'll be seen as
maybe like a genghis khan type of
character and you forget
the millions that he tortured right so
you're one of the most successful and
brilliant people
the world has ever seen so you're the
good person to ask uh
for advice you know there's a lot of
young people that look up to you
uh god bless their souls and hearts made
the right choice
what advice would you give to a young
person maybe to yourself to a young
version of yourself
you know just how to live a successful a
good life
be doggedly you i think the magic
happens when
you are stubbornly doggedly you and you
meet other people who are doing the same
and
um the real magic of life the real true
currency and this ephemeral life is sort
of
the communication that happens between
people
uh that's the real currency friendships
love it's it's cliche but it's uh
i think the meaning of life is to
experience
to experience love and uh i think uh
people often mistake maybe it's because
of hollywood films and things like that
that love is uh feeling but it's not
it's an
action so uh that took me a while to
learn and i think that's why i've made
decisions since that i think have been
good for me and healthy for me
love is an action uh people can say
things you can feel things
um that doesn't mean they're necessarily
real it's all chemical reactions
it's all uh tied to our immaturity
and uh psychological issues and uh
survival
but action when so when you do things
when you
act out of love and you that's
that's what it's about is there uh times
when you're younger where you were kind
of
this uh dishonest with who you are to
yourself
yeah in terms of like what what kind of
things did you have to do to
to shake yourself up and be like okay i
thought
um i thought i'm going to be a scientist
but instead i i realized i'm going to do
this
yeah my parents make funny yeah my
comedy is a
hard thing to explain to uh you know an
immigrant mother who came here
and under nazi occupied crete and became
a human rights lawyer and lawyer and
my brother's a lawyer and my father was
a lawyer you know clawed his way up his
dad was a
was a um to your disappointment i'm the
black sheep yeah my brother went to
oxford georgetown law
brown you know has
masters and you know good law degrees my
mother has followed four law degrees uh
you know uh she was on the human rights
commission new york up for a judgeship
under dinkins
um wrote a you know uh she was the
editor of unitard
she she wrote a seminal piece on the
human rights of children for the united
nations
um and yeah i was a comedian i was
always a [ __ ] up and uh
the thing that i was best at the only
thing i was ever decent at was just like
making people laugh i don't know why i
don't know where that comes from
but uh was there a question or did was
there a moment where you decided this is
what i'm gonna do there was a moment
after i
graduated college yeah but i was
thinking about all types of stuff that
other people imposed on me and um i was
honest with myself and uh once i figured
out it was an actual career path
i wasn't even aware back then the
internet wasn't huge you know in late 99
2000 it wasn't big yet so i didn't i
thought robin williams was just like an
actor i didn't know there was comedy
clubs and all
so once i learned that i was just like i
tried it i
suffered from massive anxiety i remember
the first time i did comedy my arms went
numb i started having a massive panic
attack i have my first set i can show it
to you it's like
i suggest i just i'm a video yeah i'm
video oh thank you thank you thank you
and the reason why i kept saying thank
you because i forgot my old jokes i was
so scared
and then they laughed because of the
amount of times i said thank you and
then once they laughed
i was i remembered the whole thing and i
did the five minutes and i remember
getting off
and for a person who never felt like he
had a place anywhere nothing ever felt
right
that felt like okay i found it this is
what i'm supposed to do
this is it it was the only time in my
life i felt that i haven't felt it since
never felt it before so that's the only
thing i can do
and um yeah i had that you know it's
funny because there's uh i've
similar experience like immigrant family
and the world tells you to do certain
things
and you think that's right but but then
you put yourself in situations by luck
probably
where it's like oh this this this is
this feels right
i don't know what this means but this
feels right i think the
the the biggest moment like that for me
was uh i don't know
what to make of it exactly but when i
met
spot the robot the legged robot it was
like five years
ago it felt like this
there the depth of fascinating ideas
that are yet to be explored with this
thing this felt like a journey it was
like a door that opened
and i was like i don't want to be a
professor
at that point i realized i don't want to
do sort of uh generic stuff i want to do
something crazy i want to do something
big
that's the reason i stepped away from
mit that's the reason i have this
burning desire to do a startup that's
the reason i came to austin
yeah i don't know what the hell it all
means but you just kind of follow that
that's awesome
that sounds like you're following what's
doggedly you and also i think
uh just to just to piggyback off it i
think that means
no matter what it is because i think our
uh the american dream is sold like hey
if you're not
beyonce or if you're not famous you're
not worth it i
hate that and that's what i love so much
about certain countries like sweden it's
a
it's like um where everyone has
healthcare and stuff like that because
everyone's a little
is valued more it's like whatever if you
want to be a doormat dude like
it's all the same prince was not happy
there's no
just because you're rich or famous
you're still the same guy
with your possessions are a lot little
you know it's like
i i i have met some doormen i have met
some tax covers that
i a lot of you not are more fascinating
i have comedians are horrible people
i want to get away from all that i have
very few friends
paul versi tim dillon who are comedians
because they're awful awful people
some of the people who you know the most
who are the most famous
are not who they say they are usually
that's the case they're putting on that
public facade because they're [ __ ]
sociopaths
yeah they're horrible people and some of
the most beautiful people i've met and
the most interesting people
i've met have regular jobs there's no
shame in
any [ __ ] job we don't all have to be
rappers
with like rims it's just a weird thing
yeah famous
fame is a drug and yeah comedians i
agree with you
there's some part of me that knows that
there'll be a moment in my life when i'm
standing there
with like a sword or a knife in my
stomach
and looking at tim dillon's smiling face
saying uh uh you shouldn't have trusted
me
you stupid [ __ ] so on that note
be honest i've been a huge fan of yours
i love what you're doing with long days
now your new podcast and um i obviously
love
all the stuff you've done before with
history hyenas the chemistry
the the chemistry you have with yourself
it's also fun to watch so man i'm a huge
fan it's a huge honor that you come down
here
thanks so much for talking today it
means so much to me to hear you say that
i really appreciate i'm a big fan of
yours and
have meown's been amazing and just thank
you man thank you for having me on and
people if they want to watch my special
it's called blowing the light it's on
youtube and please come listen to long
days of the podcast
let's go eat some barbecue let's do it
thanks for listening to this
conversation with janice pappas
and thank you to wine access blinkist
magic spoon and indeed check them out in
the description to support this podcast
and now let me leave you with some words
from karl marx
revolutions are the locomotives of
history
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time